[Music]
Today we already had a very
intensive discussion about the future of
the common agricultural policy and I
am very pleased that we brought together a certain
amount of clarity and, above all,
progress
. Today we have three topics from the very
extensive agenda that I have
on the one hand,
there is progress in the
further development of the common
agricultural policy on the proposal by
commissioner hogan, on the other hand, the
completion of the process for nominating
a joint candidate for the
general director of the fao, and, thirdly,
the burning issue
of african swine fever
essentially, the discussion
concentrated on two thermal bath topics
, on the one hand, the new implementation model
and, on the other hand, the new environmental architecture
[music]